hey guys in this video I'm going to talk
about sleepy after eating do you get
sleepy after you eat sometimes people
think that's a normal thing it's not
normal to be tired after you eat okay it
usually comes from two different reasons
number one when you eat you trigger
insulin because and that makes that
means the blood sugars are going to go
high it's like kind of after
Thanksgiving meal everyone wants to take
a nap because there's high sugar okay so
if you're taking putting these breads in
your body and even sugar and especially
combining like something like some soda
some sugar with the protein that's a
deadly combination or even some pasta
dish you are going to get tired because
the blood sugar effect so what you need
to do is change your foods cut out the
refined sugars cut out the breads pasta
cereal crackers viscous waffles pancakes
and just have like a salad with some
protein not too much just enough just a
little bit maybe the deck of a card like
three to six ounces and then what you
can do is consume a little bit of fat as
well okay why because we had a little
fat we can actually allow us to go
longer and without eating be more
satisfied so we keep insulin low okay
now number two it could be that you're
not digesting your food so the food just
kind of sits there and you'll feel
bloated in that case we need to acidify
your stomach a lot of times that'll just
kind of perk you right up so you can
either do apple cider vinegar in water
and drink that with the meal or you can
do it in pills outside up in a group
Plus that has a couple other things in
there take that before you you eat and
boom the food digests and you won't get
tired anymore okay so it could be those
combinations so how do you know what you
need well if you cut out the sugar and
eat healthy and you're still tired then
we know you can't digest so then we have
to add these set of fires okay plus if
the food sits there it doesn't digest
you feel bloated that means we need to
actually support the digestion not
necessarily the blood sugars okay so
hope that helped
go ahead and apply that put your
comments below your success stories